en este vídeo daremos un panorama
general de los tipos de mercados que
podrías encontrar en una clase de
economía y vamos a ser precisos con
nuestro lenguaje porque con frecuencia
escucharás palabras como competencia
perfecta o monopolio u oligopolio en
economía incluso las escucharás en más
ámbitos de tu vida ahora antes de que
entremos en esos términos distinguir en
lo que a veces se denomina mercado de
productos
y otros mercados que se conocen como
mercados de recursos
ahora el mercado de productos es un
mercado donde se está produciendo o lo
que se está comprando y vendiendo es
algo que la gente consumirá y no sólo
tiene que ser un producto físico sino
que también puede ser algún tipo de
servicio por lo tanto el mercado de
camisas de automóviles o incluso un
servicio podrían ser ejemplos de
mercados de productos podría ser la
declaración de impuestos la declaración
de impuestos
todos estos serían mercados de productos
porque es algo que la gente consumir ya
yo llamaría a esto la declaración del
impuesto del consumidor no la
declaración de impuestos empresarial así
que esta es la declaración del impuesto
del consumidor
ahora con base en mi aclaración tal vez
puedas adivinar de qué se trata un
mercado de recursos estos son mercados
para los insumos de otros productos o
incluso en la producción de otros
recursos por lo tanto esto serían los
famosos insumos o factores de producción
podría ser por ejemplo el mercado de
trabajo podría ser algo así como tierras
vivo donde las tierras de cultivo se
utilizan para producir algo más podría
ser el mercado de bienes de capital
tal vez robots para fábricas pero de
cualquier manera ya sea que estemos
hablando de mercados de productos o
mercados de recursos podemos pensar en
ellos en términos generales basados en
cuántos jugadores hay en el mercado y
cuan diferenciados están los jugadores
en el mercado y cuánto control tienen
sobre el precio y cómo son las barreras
para entrar en el mercado vamos a
establecer un espacio aquí para explorar
esto un poco así que voy a configurar
este espacio ahora en el extremo del
espacio donde solo tienes un jugador
cuando nos referimos a jugador en el
mercado es una empresa en el mercado y
digamos muchos compradores muchos
compradores probablemente estés
familiarizado con la forma en que
llamamos a este mercado o como
llamaríamos a esta empresa es un
monopolio tiene el nombre de monopolio
de un juego famoso donde el objetivo de
ese juego es tratar de ser la última
empresa en pie
para que logré tener todos los bienes
inmuebles ahora cuáles son las
situaciones que describirían un
monopolio bueno un monopolio es una
situación donde tienes altas barreras a
la entrada alguien podría argumentar que
son tan altas que son barreras
insuperables muy altas altas barreras a
la entrada de nuevas empresas y los
monopolios a veces pueden ser
controvertidos pero no son
necesariamente ilegales de hecho en
muchos países se puede otorgar un
monopolio a una empresa a través de
cosas como la propiedad intelectual o
las patentes por ejemplo si una compañía
farmacéutica descubre una cura para una
droga o algo para mantener una droga
bueno podría otorgarse un monopolio para
esa píldora por un periodo de tiempo y
el gobierno lo hace para que puedan
recuperar su inversión en toda la
investigación y desarrollo que hicieron
lo que a menudo es ilegal en muchos
países es que la empresa haga un mal uso
de su poder de monopolio pero de
cualquier forma ahora vamos al otro
extremo imaginemos una situación donde
el lugar de alta
barreras a la entrada no hay barreras no
hay barreras a la entrada ahora digamos
que no hay diferenciación y tienes
muchos jugadores déjenme escribir muchas
empresas sigo queriendo decir jugadores
pero eso no lo deja tan claro y en
realidad permítanme decir muchas
empresas y muchos compradores muchos
compradores ahora este es un estado que
a menudo estudiaremos en nuestra clase
de economía lo llamaremos competencia
perfecta competencia perfecta en un
mundo de competencia perfecta las
empresas esencialmente tienen que ser
precio aceptantes toman el precio de
mercado cualquiera que sea y hemos usado
ese supuesto en muchas situaciones por
otro lado en un monopolio son fijadores
de precios son del único jugador en ese
mercado ahora en general cuando algo se
describe como perfecto generalmente es
teórico y también lo es la competencia
perfecta
hay mercados en los que pueda pensar que
sean completamente perfectos pero puedo
pensar en mercados que están cerca de
serlo por ejemplo algunos productos
agrícolas digamos el mercado del azúcar
así que el mercado del azúcar podría
estar bastante cerca de la competencia
perfecta podría haber muchas empresas
que serían los agricultores los
oferentes obviamente son muchos los
compradores que quieren azúcar habría
algunas barreras de entrada necesitas
saber cómo cultivar azúcar necesitas una
tierra adecuada para cultivar azúcar
pero hay muchos agricultores que podrían
cambiar a la caña de azúcar oa la
remolacha que es de donde proviene la
mayor parte del azúcar con soya o
viceversa por lo tanto pueden cambiar
los cultivos que siembran y en general
no hay mucha diferencia ción entre
obtener azúcar de una granja u otra así
que el azúcar estaría muy cerca de la
competencia perfecta y es el caso de
muchos productos agrícolas que tienen
que ser precio aceptantes sólo hay un
precio de mercado y el agricultor
individual lo tiene que aceptar
sin embargo si en un momento dice que en
realidad quiere cobrar un poco más por
esa azúcar no podrá hacerlo solo podrá
tomar el precio que esté en el mercado
ahora como puedes imaginar hay muchos
otros tipos de mercados que se
encuentran entre estos extremos lo más
cercano a un monopolio o algo similar a
un monopolio en muchos sentidos es una
situación en la que solo tienes un
puñado de empresas y eso se refiere al
oligopolio y esta es una situación en la
que todavía tienes altas barreras altas
barreras a la entrada es posible que
tengas un puñado de empresas de modo que
tenemos pocas empresas y todavía tienes
muchos compradores la industria
aeronáutica es un ejemplo de oligopolio
aeronáutica donde hay enormes barreras a
la entrada necesitas una gran cantidad
de miles de millones de pesos de capital
es posible que tengas que obtener la
aprobación del gobierno y es por eso
especialmente para los aviones grandes
que sólo tienen unas pocas empresas que
pueden producir el boeing o el airbús
esos aviones que son realmente grandes
incluso en ciertos casos los automóviles
a veces los fabricantes de computadoras
cosas que tienen muy altas barreras a la
entrada si nos movemos un poco más hacia
la izquierda tenemos una situación que
se conoce como competencia monopolística
y esto lo podrías ver justo en el medio
dependiendo de lo que estés pensando
esta es una situación en la que las
barreras a la entrada son bajas bajas
barreras a la entrada hay muchas
empresas muchas empresas pero tienes
diferenciación tienes una diferenciación
por lo que puedes distinguir el producto
de una empresa del de otra y puedo
pensar en muchas de hecho la mayoría de
las industrias en las que puedo pensar
caen aproximadamente en el área
monopolística aunque acabamos de
mencionar algunos oligopolios y
monopolios pero puedo imaginar ejemplos
de competencia monopolística como
cereales cereales para el desayuno y en
la industria de cereales para el
desayuno hay muchas empresas
realmente hay pequeñas barreras hay
algunas barreras pero son bastante
pequeñas
si quieres iniciar una empresa de
cereales muchas personas podrían hacerlo
pero hay alguna diferenciación algunas
empresas dicen que sus cereales más
delicioso y más dulce mientras que otras
dicen que su cereal es más nutritivo y
construyen una marca y hacen publicidad
etcétera etcétera y debido a que hay una
cierta diferenciación hay un poco más de
capacidad para las empresas a diferencia
de la competencia perfecta para dictar
su precio podrían decir oye somos un
producto premium la gente piensa que
nuestro producto es más saludable por lo
que podríamos cobrar un poco más casi
puedes imaginar que tienen su propia y
única curva de demanda por esa
diferenciación puedes imaginar el
mercado en algo como camisas ese es otro
ejemplo muchas personas pueden producir
camisas pero algunas personas pueden
diferenciarse son más elegantes hay
mejor calidad se anuncian construyen una
marca
y así una vez más eso sería competencia
monopolística de cualquier forma el
panorama general en realidad es para que
te familiarices con esas palabras que
quieren decir y cuál es el contexto o
que implica la diferenciación de un
producto o el número de empresas y en
realidad antes de terminar diré otra
palabra que oirás un poco menos de lo
que acabo de hablar y parece un
monopolio pero es monopsonio monopsonio
lo cual no escucharás tanto como el
monopolio y en realidad es la situación
opuesta en lugar de un proveedor y
muchos compradores un monopolio es un
gran comprador y muchos proveedores
entonces por ejemplo si tienes una gran
tienda en una ciudad pequeña y es el
único empleador en esa ciudad pueden
tener un monopolio en el mercado laboral
donde ellos son los únicos que pueden
contratar y hay muchas personas que
buscan trabajo pero podemos hablar más
sobre eso en otros vídeos hasta el
próximo vídeo